herr lauterbach würden sie sagen dieses
gesetz ist unwirksam bevor es kommt also
ich glaube schon dass es eine gewisse
wirkung hatte ich bin daher dankbar auch
das also überhaupt initiative jetzt in
gang geraten ist durch also olaf scholz
durch angela merkel das ist unbedingt
notwendig weil damit schon alleine diese
lockerungen die jetzt also überall
gemacht werden in form von
modellversuchen aufhören das halte ich
für gift in der jetzigen situation die
also lockerungen die wir derzeit in
modellversuchen haben das sind alibi
veranstaltung wo man im prinzip den
geschlossenen aus der notbremsen
mechanismus um laufen will und das
findet ja an vielen stellen noch platz
sind auch in vier ich denn noch immer
die geschäfte offen sondern die schulen
sind offen
trotzdem darf man sich keine illusionen
hingeben also diese notbremse die jetzt
zu spät oder sehr spät kommt aber
trotzdem einen gewissen wert hat selbst
wenn sie nicht verwässert würde dann
würde sie die dritte welle nicht bremst
und nicht wirklich nennenswert bremsen
wir werden irgendwann im laufe der
nächsten woche über die instanz von 200
weg gehen
die intensivstationen sind schon voll
wir praktizieren in vielen großen
städten schon die sogenannte weiche
trial zum beispiel in köln schicken wir
bestimmte leute nicht mehr in die
uni-klinik obwohl sie dort besser
behandelt werden könnten wir sagen
bestimmte eingriffe ab weil wir die
intensivpflege danach nicht mehr
anbieten können wir sind also mit der
intensiv kapazität und auch also mit den
fallzahlen sind wir schon am rand und
das läuft ja noch für drei oder vier
wochen weiter mit den fahrzeugen die wir
jetzt auf gelernt haben dass wir müssen
weit über das hinausgehen
wir verlieren sehr viel zeit etwas zu
beschließen das eine
selbstverständlichkeit ist das ist ja
wie ein tank hat er sehr langsam die
richtung also wechseln kann
ich glaube wir werden sehr lange in
diesem loch down über 100 bleiben denn
erst mal unter die 100 weg zu kommen
damit die notbremse wieder gelöst werden
kann wo wir erst mal in der nächsten
woche über die 200 gehen werden das wird
lange dauern da muss mehr passieren
claudia kade ist bei uns von der welt
kollegin die das politik ressort leitet
pokale besteht nicht nur die gefahr dass
dieses gesetz zu spät kommt sondern das
ist gar nicht kommt das ist so viel
widerspruch und einspruch gibt von den
ministerpräsidenten respektive dass die
sagen wir machen das jetzt am besten
schon wie baden-württemberg bilden
montag einführen
schleswig holstein nicht aber
mecklenburg vorpommern will motor schon
einführt kann es sein dass wir über ein
gesetz reden dass es gar nicht braucht
also es geht ja erstmal jetzt in den
nächsten tagen darum dass die fraktionen
von union und spd sich einig werden und
da muss ich herrn scholz sagen so wie
sie sich das vorstellen wird das
wahrscheinlich nächste woche nicht im
bundestag verabschiedet werden wenn es
überhaupt verabschiedet wird dann nicht
aus innerer überzeugung so wie ich das
glaube bei den unions spd abgeordneten
zu hören sondern eher um ihre führung
nicht zu düpieren also die fragen der
ausgangssperre die frage der
parlamentsbeteiligung wie ernst es die
wirklich gemeint wie umsetzbar ist sie
tatsächlich die frage
orientiert man sich weiterhin vor allem
nur an der incidents all das sind fragen
die in ihre fraktion besprochen werden
in der unionsfraktion sehr strittig sind
und auch die frage tatsächlich ist der
klageweg für die bürger wenn sie sich
gegen diese maßnahmen zur wehr setzen
möchten denn das über eine über ein
bundesgesetz und über bundes
verordnungen kommt dann ist der weg
eigentlich nur noch über das
verfassungsgericht möglich all das sind
sachen die bei ihnen in der fraktion
auch bei der union noch sehr sehr hart
diskutiert werden und über das
wochenende wird sich dann tatsächlich
klären was man da nicht einen weg findet
wir schalten gleichen beherrscht sie
halten noch ganz kurz an wir begrüßen
noch den vorsitzenden der fdp bei uns in
der runde christian lindner
ralph brinkhaus hat gesagt im grunde
liegen alle argumente auf den tisch es
wäre jetzt wichtig zu handeln
herrn villa habe ich schon zitiert herr
villa hat appelliert an die
entscheidungsträger nicht an die
menschen in diesem land sondern an die
politiker tut jetzt endlich was daneben
saß ein gesundheitsminister der sagte
tut jetzt endlich was also der
appellierte an politiker an die
politiker was glauben sie wielange darf
dieser prozess jetzt dauern und liegen
nicht eigentlich alle argumente auf dem
tisch ich teile den appell dass
gehandelt werden muss
okay das ist auch mein dringender appell
länder und landkreise haben jetzt schon
alle rechtlichen möglichkeiten
und es muss jetzt auch etwas passieren
ich bin regelmäßig in kontakt mit
medizinern wie heute noch unterrichten
lassen vom chef der charité über die
aktuelle situation wir lesen die
inzidenz zahlen deshalb ist jetzt
handeln nötig aber das richtige muss
getan werden
wir müssen die maßnahmen einleiten die
tatsächlich wirksam sind und das ganze
muss verfassungsrechtlich sauber laufen
so dass es kein vertrauensverlust in die
politik gibt weil ein gesetz
beispielsweise vom verfassungsgericht
wieder verworfen wird
ich glaube was wir tun müssen ist das
massive ausweitende tests
ich halte es für richtig dass in den
hoch incidents gebieten die kontakte die
einzelnen haushalten erlaubt sind
eingeschränkt werden ich halte es im
übrigen auch für möglich dass wir das im
tempo weiter erhöhen indem alle länder
alle reserven an impfstoff jetzt für
impfen der zeitpunkt zwischen erst und
zweitens gestreckt wird und bei den
niedergelassenen bereich voll mit
einbeziehen ich könnte die liste dessen
was zu tun ist weiter fortsetzen
aber der frage wie heute es brennt in
beiden fraktionen noch einen satz sagen
nur dass ich jetzt nicht verstehe ist
diese maßnahmen die sinnvoll wären
liegen auf dem tisch
und ausgerechnet wieder mit heißer nadel
gestrickt kommt die regierung mit einem
gesetz das die offensichtlich pauschal
nicht wirksame ausgangssperre zum
gegenstand hat dass jede möglichkeit
test basierten öffnens wie die sogar in
bayern jetzt möglich sind ausschließt
und sich alleine orientiert auf dieser
hunderte incident und das ist nicht
sachgerecht und verfassungsrechtlich
problematisch und deshalb mein appell an
die regierung wenn sie sich um eine
breite mehrheit bemühen will
und wenn sie ein verfassungsrechtlich
sicheres gesetz durch den bundestag
bringen will
über das wochenende die wirklich gut
gemeinten argumente aufzunehmen so der
herr scholz ist so lieb und wartet noch
eine sekunde weil es gibt sicher eine
interessante haltung aus den ländern und
vor allen dingen aus niedersachsen da
ist und zugeschaltet der
stellvertretende
herr altmann einen schönen guten abend
nach hannover klare frage ist dieses
gesetz von der bundeskanzlerin und dem
vizekanzler gut vorbereitet wenn es
einsprüche und widersprüche der
ministerpräsidenten kollegen gibt
übrigens auch iris also stephan weil hat
genauso protestiert wie herr kretschmar
und rasen ist das ein gut vorbereitetes
gesetz inzwischen kann ich sagen dass
die bundesländer an der weiteren
gesetzgebung mitgewirkt haben es sind
zahlreiche vorschläge gemacht worden
von daher bin ich persönlich der
auffassung dass wir jetzt mal wirklich
langsam zu einem ergebnis kommen müssen
und es stimmt jeder tag der ungenutzt
vergeht bedeutet eine zusätzliche
gefährdung der bevölkerung man darf
verfassungsrechtliche fragen in den
vordergrund stellt man darf auch
hinterfragen ob in den letzten zwölf
monaten alles richtig gemacht haben und
das mit sicherheit nicht so dass wir
nichts getan hätten
nur der bund hat letztendlich auf einen
punkt hingewiesen die zurückliegende
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen haben
sich nicht auf ein einheitliches
vorgehen zwischen den bundesländern
zugegeben die haben unterschiedliche
voraussetzungen einigen können und
deshalb hat der bund gesagt ab einer
100er inzidenz will man eingreifen
können
die bundesländer haben aber alle
möglichkeiten ihre instrumente und sie
sind für den infektionsschutz zuständig
auch tatsächlich jetzt schon einzusetzen
also insofern ich gehe am ende davon aus
dass es einen einstimmigen beschluss
zugunsten dieses gesetzes oder zumindest
eine mehrheit dafür geben würde
herr scholz jetzt sind wir bei ihnen
jens spahn sagt heute ruft heute der
bundesgesundheitsminister ruft heute die
ministerpräsidenten auf nicht zu warten
bis diese bundes lockdown bis diese
bundes notbremse kommt sondern gleich zu
handeln warum brauchen wir dann
eigentlich ein bundesgesetz das noch
dazu so umstritten
ich glaube dass es zu einer klarstellung
in der debatte beitragen wird auch dazu
dass die präzision bei der umsetzung
zunimmt was ganz wichtig ist ich glaube
es hat sehr geschadet dass es dann doch
eben wie zu viele schlupflöcher
löcher gegeben hat über all die werden
jetzt zugemacht das hilft aber allen
auch der debatte in ganz deutschland und
der dem vertrauen in die regelung und
natürlich ist es so dass viele länder
vieles von dem auch schon umgesetzt
haben
darum ist das jetzt einfach ein
konsolidierungsschritte aber
gleichzeitig mehr klarheit und mehr
umsetzungsstärke bringt in den
fraktionen darauf hat frauke hingewiesen
ist eine menge los die bekommen nicht
nur zarte hinweise aus den verschiedenen
spd-regierten ländern sondern es melden
sich ihr parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer und andere mehr
wir müssen spaziergänger ermöglichen
sonst kriegen die leute einen knall
wir gehen an das gesetz rein und
verändern die ausgangssperre damit sport
und spazierengehen mit dem eigenen
hausstand erlaubt bleiben
so auch juristen im kanzleramt sollen
zweifel haben an der rechtmässigkeit
herr scholz er droht ihnen da einfach
eine blamage kann es sein dass das
irgendwie vom bundesverfassungsgericht
kassiert wird und was wäre dann
schlimmer es ist ja viel schlimmer als
wenn ein landes verwaltungsgerichts sagt
nena nicht ängstlichkeit ist kein guter
ratgeber für handeln in einer
krisensituation es geht jetzt schon
darum dass wir entschlossen vorgehen
und wir haben das alles juristisch
überprüft die beiden verfassungsressorts
das justizministerium das
innenministerium sind sich sicher dass
diese gesetzgebung genau den regeln des
verfassungsgerichts entspricht ich
übrigens auch
natürlich entscheidet das
bundesverfassungsgericht das muss man ja
mit allem respekt dazu sagen aber ich
glaube schon dass das alles sehr wichtig
ist im übrigen haben wir viele dieser
maßnahmen schon in den ländern
wirklichkeit gefunden und das hat dazu
geführt dass auch gerichte das überprüft
haben manche sind nicht so glücklich
gewesen aber viele haben das akzeptiert
und deshalb sind wir deshalb sind wir
ganz sicher dass das auch funktioniert
was der gesundheitsminister gesagt habe
ist etwas worüber ich mit allen ländern
auch gesprochen habe mit dem nicht
diskutiert habe dass sie entweder
bereits viele dieser maßnahmen umgesetzt
haben und das ohnehin können
und insofern sind wir uns ohnehin einig
es geht hier um ein
konsolidierungsschritt in hinblick auf
die notbremse damit nicht mehr der
eindruck vorherrscht alles geht
durcheinander und das ist hilfreich gut
unterrichtete jetzt haben natürlich
landes verwaltungs und
oberlandesgerichte entschieden dass es
eben ausgangssperren in einzelnen
bundesländern nicht geben soll
wir reden gleich nochmal über die
ausgangssperre war das ja der euro ist
der ausgangs beschränkung reden aber
auch sie muss nicht darüber müssen wir
uns nicht streiten streiten wir uns
nicht an der juristischen expertise bei
diesen pandemie beschränkungen
angebracht ich meine wir erinnern uns an
die oster ruhe die auch in loyalisten
reinlässt wir dürfen gar nichts machen
aber das ist typisch für angela merkel
hat die oster ruhe die sogenannte nach
diesem nacht beschlossen mit der
ministerpräsident konferenz ja selber
wieder zurückgezogen weil es einfach
nicht machbar war
und das ist eben einer der faktoren bei
dem man wirklich als zuschauer und
beobachter dieser ganzen situation nur
den kopf schütteln kann
die sowohl feilen sätze die wir auch
eben von herrn althusmann gehört haben
jeder tag zählt und wir haben eigentlich
einen notbremsen beschluss seit dem
dritten märz also seit fast sieben
wochen
das sind die punkte weshalb die zweifel
wachsen an den tatsächlichen an der
gründlichkeit an der an der vernunft und
an der seriosität ihrer politik das will
ich da an diesem punkt weil anlagen darf
die ausgangs beschränkungen
da kann man folgendes sagen zumal sie
sind wissenschaftlich sehr gut
untersucht worden haben 110 regionen
unterwegs
sie haben funktioniert wir kommen auf
jeden fall zu dieser inhaltlichen
diskussionen noch wir würden gerade noch
mal verstehen was da eigentlich zwischen
bund und ländern passiert weil die
situation war wir hatten eine mpk die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat nicht
so geliefert und hat ein großes argument
loswerden er ich habe ja an vielen ich
habe an diesem ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen teilgenommen
ich habe
weil ich mit vielen befreundeten
ministerpräsidenten ministerpräsidenten
auf diskutiere einen guten überblick
über die diskussion die in den ländern
stattgefunden haben wenn sie jeweils
ihre krone regelungen festgelegt haben
alle paar wochen und die diskussion
waren immer intensiv so wie sie das
jetzt auch sind im deutschen bundestag
was wir jetzt erleben ist also ein ganz
normaler vorgang dass angesichts der
gesetzgebung sich viele mit vielen
detailfragen zur wortmeldung trotzdem
wird die gesetzgebung der voranschreiten
und nächste woche zu einem ergebnis
führen
und genau da ist noch arbeit erleben
doch jetzt nur mit was sowieso alle paar
wochen überall in den ländern und auch
in den verschiedenen gesprächen zwischen
bund und ländern über stattgefunden hat
aber die tatsache dass auch in dieser
sendung an den vielen anderen
diskussionen beklagt worden ist dass man
nicht mehr durchblickt die müssen wir
jetzt ja mal mit einem klaren regeln
sich davon nicht ob man muss doch in
einem punkt ihnen recht geben dass wir
ein bundeseinheitliches regelwerk
bekommt es ist richtig ich glaube
überfällig wir hatten auch schon
gelegenheit in dieser sendung vor
monaten darüber zu sprechen klare wenn
dann regeln wären sinnvoll in einem
bestimmten fall bei einem bestimmten
pandemie geschehen vor ort sind solche
maßnahmen nötig das ist richtig diese
eigentlich richtige absicht wird nur
gegenwärtig ich glaube auch aufgrund der
sehr kurzen vorbereitungszeit mindestens
unvollkommen umgesetzt wenn wir gleich
in der sache darüber sprechen können wir
die kritikpunkte aufbringen es gibt nur
den einen fall der notbremse die
hunderter incidents und das ist deshalb
ein problem weil an diese eine zahl
automatisch wirksam
freiheitsbeschränkungen gebunden das ist
auch schon das wird hier ja aber das
wird der situation vor ort nicht gerecht
ich sage ein kurzes beispiel wir haben
ein landkreis und in diesem landkreis
hat man an einer stelle einen ausbruch
wir hatten das etwa bei
fleischverarbeitenden betrieben
dann weiß man aber und kann
nachverfolgen woher kommt die hohe zahl
und dann gibt es andere fälle etwa in
flensburg gab es das einmal da waren
plötzlich hohe zahlen da und die
behörden wussten nicht mehr bekommen
plötzlich diese vielen erkrankungen
dieses 4 und infektionen her da ist
übrigens damals sogar von einem fdp-
gesundheitsminister in schleswig
holstein einmal eine ausgangssperre
auf verhangen worden also da darf man ja
nicht paniert sagen wenn es notwendig
ist genau im januar dann muss das getan
werden aber es wurde eben vor ort
geschaut was ist konkret die lage und da
sehe ich einen ganz großen kritikpunkt
bei ihrer jetzigen bundeseinheitlichen
regelung es ist nicht mehr möglich vor
ort die lage zu bewerten und dann die
notwendigen maßnahmen einzuleiten und
ich glaube dass deshalb auch der
landkreistag das sind ja die
praktikerinnen und praktiker vor ort gar
von einem misstrauensvotum sprechen
ich finde das hat die kommunale ebene wo
er auch viele sozialdemokraten tätig
sind so nicht verdient in die wahl
entschieden anderer meinung als sie ich
finde in einer inzidenz von 100
infektionen auf 100.000 einwohnerinnen
und einwohnern sehr hoch und ich glaube
dass das nicht mehr der fall ist wo man
klugerweise differenziert sind wurden
dann auch diese regeln automatisch
gelten müssen
und eigentlich haben sie ja mit ihrem
beitrag deutlich gemacht warum wir die
bundeseinheitliche automatische regelung
brauchen
es gibt so viele diskussionen dass am
ende niemand mehr etwas umsetzt und
entscheiden sie erinnern sich an die
gesundheitsämter die einen brief
geschrieben haben und gesagt haben
in sidenten sind eben so oder so
auszulegen sie können 150er instituts
haben die ist ganz schlimm weil sie
viele risiko und menschen betrifft und
sie können 150er incident haben die es
überhaupt nicht schlimm weil sie in
einem cluster von 20 oder 30 jährigen
liegt bevor wir inhaltlich diskutieren
möchte ich unbedingt und an dieser
stelle juristischen beistand hinein
holen und zwar von under license berger
sie ist recht professorin an der
universität in jena und wird uns jetzt
helfen bei der beantwortung der frage
welche juristischen bedenken es ganz
konkret gibt einen schönen guten abend
frau die leisten abend was die kanzlerin
und ihr vizekanzler tun was die da
machen das ist im sinne der verfassung
fragezeichen
es gibt ein infektionsschutzgesetz und
das kann erweitert werden
im sinne der verfassung ist tatsächlich
die frage man muss auf der einen seite
sagen dass der bund die
gesetzgebungskompetenz hat für das
infektionsschutzgesetz und zwar für das
infektionsschutz recht in seiner
gesamtheit das heißt insbesondere auch
soweit schulen betroffen sind wenn also
lehrpläne jetzt neu justiert werden
müssen was ja eigentlich in die
kulturhoheit der länder hinein reicht
ist das trotzdem im schwerpunkt
infektionsschutz recht und insoweit
fällt das in die konkurrierende
gesetzgebungs zuständigkeit des bundes
auf der anderen seite hat man sich im
letzten jahr mit durchaus guten gründen
dafür entschieden im bundesrecht also im
bundes infektionsschutzgesetz nur einen
sehr weiten rahmen vorzusehen und den
ländern insoweit spielräume zuzugestehen
um eben wie es herr lindner auch gerade
gesagt hat auf die regionalen
besonderheiten auch speziell einzugehen
und das macht auch das
infektionsgeschehen dann vor ort
greifbar man kann auch die erfahrungen
der kommunen zurückgreifen
und was jetzt gemacht werden soll ab
einer inzidenz von 100 ist den grundsatz
anzuwenden bundesrecht bricht
landesrecht das heißt es wird das signal
ausgesendet an die länder ihr könnte es
nicht ihr habt es nicht gemacht sowie
das infektions sprecht das verlangt und
das ist kein gutes signal und das ist
auch nicht im sinne des föderalismus
prinzips und damit auch nicht im sinne
des grundgesetzes aber noch mal es ist
hier an diesem infektionsschutzgesetz
sehr lange gearbeitet und immer wieder
gearbeitet worden hätte man denn mit
einem anderen also beispielsweise mit
diesen nun erarbeiteten stufenplan der
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
arbeit wenn das zu einer
bundesgesetzgebung oder novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes geworden wäre
wäre das denn ein kluger gedanke man
hätte klare richtlinien und jedes land
kann danach urteilen was anzuwenden ist
das ist grundsätzlich durchaus zu
überlegen ob man jetzt in das
infektionsschutzgesetz solche stufen
hineinschreibt man hätte das auch schon
früher machen können wir haben dort
allerdings auch schon gewisse stufen was
man allerdings verabsäumt hat und was
man natürlich jetzt mit dem wissen von
heute auch früher anders gemacht hätte
ist bei den hohen inzidenz das heißt wer
den instanzen ab 100 daneben ganz
konkrete maßnahmen greifen zu lassen das
hat man insbesondere nicht gemacht und
das war natürlich im rückblick ein
fehler das hat den ländern insoweit zu
viel spielräume gelassen was jetzt
geschieht bevor lebens berger ist dass
einzelne ministerpräsidenten für sich
festlegen diese diesen bundes lockt also
das beschlossene vom dritten dritten im
grunde jetzt schon umzusetzen und nicht
auf den bundes parlamentarischen prozess
zu warten
was bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich nehmen
sich damit die ministerpräsidenten ihre
macht wieder zurück hat angela merkel
damit aber wenigstens erreicht dass
jetzt alle auf sie hören wie ist das zu
werten in ihren augen
ja ich glaube sie sehen ist vollkommen
richtig angela merkel wollte ja im
wesentlichen politischen druck erst
einmal ausüben auf die länder dass die
endlich tätig werden im sinne der
vereinbarten notbremse und wenn die
ministerpräsidenten jetzt von sich aus
tätig werden und in ihren ländern
das ebenso regeln wie das auch
vereinbart war dann hätte man auch eine
juristisch insofern saubere lösung als
dann die verwaltungsgerichte unter
berücksichtigung der örtlichen
besonderheiten dann auch die richtigen
differenzierten entscheidungen treffen
können und dann wäre nicht alles
monopolisiert beim
bundesverfassungsgericht okay da haben
wir ihre meinung auch der dafür ist ja
die folge wir streiten jetzt sofort im
anschluss über die ausgangssperre das
ist offensichtlich auch ein heißes
politisches aber erst recht ein heißes
juristisches thema ist eine solche
ausgangs beschränkung
sie jetzt vorgesehen wird von 21 uhr bis
5 uhr unter dem pandemischen bedingungen
akzeptabel in ihren augen oder nicht ist
eine zu große einschränkung in
anbetracht der jetzigen situation also
eine ausgangs beschränkung ist auf jeden
fall ein sehr starker eingriff in die
grundrechte in die freiheit der person
das ist das grundrecht das im
grundgesetz am stärksten geschützt ist
es ist dort doppelt geschützt zum einen
inhaltlich im grundrechtskatalog und
dann auch noch mal formell dass es eben
nur durch ein förmliches gesetz geändert
werden soll auch aus historischen
gründen ist das ein ganz besonders
wichtiges grundrecht und es ist durchaus
ein erheblicher eingriff wenn die
menschen zu hause
faktisch eingesperrt werden wenn man
sich die gründe ansieht die zumindest im
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung bisher
enthalten sind die ausnahmen von dieser
ausgangssperre so sind das wirklich nur
sehr wenige
sie hatten es in ihrem beitrag erwähnt
medizinische gründe berufliche
indikationen und das ausführen des
hundes und im übrigen kann man
beispielsweise abends nicht schocken
es ist auf jeden fall kein gutes rechts
politisches signal weil es wird den
jungen leuten insbesondere die natürlich
ihre sozialen kontakte irgendwie pflegen
wollen jetzt klar gemacht ihr neues
zuhause bleiben weil draußen drohen die
bußgelder und das ist ja genau das
falsche
wenn sie mich jetzt fragen nach der
verhältnismäßigkeit
dann würde ich sagen die frage ist
tatsächlich ob es ein milderes mittel
gibt um das eigentliche ziel der
pandemie nämlich den schutz von leben
und gesundheit letztlich zu
verwirklichen und da kann man auch nicht
nur die ausgangssperre isoliert in den
blick nehmen sondern muss sie sehen als
teil eines gesamtpakets
und dazu gehören natürlich auch die
tests pflichten für betriebe um zwar im
sinne einer echten test pflicht dazu
und es gehört auch ein verpflichtendes
home office auch wenn das die
unternehmen schmerzt aber das bringt
eben auch nach wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnissen deutlich mehr als diese
pauschale ausgangssperre
wer sind sie fern würde ich sagen die
ausgangssperre ist so pauschal wie sie
jetzt vorgesehen ist nicht
verfassungsmäßig und ich verstehe sie
richtig dass es durchaus wichtig wäre
das wenn man sie erweckt dass es dann
adäquat in den betrieben als auch in den
schulen tests geben muss verpflichtende
tests geben muss weil das eben auch die
bereiche sind in denen viel ansteckungen
stattfindet sie nicken weil ich es
einigermaßen richtig zusammen gefasst
habe ja gut dann danken wir herzlich
analyse regensberger der
rechtsprofessoren von der universität
jena und gehen hier sofort in die runde
sind bei karl lauterbach
herr lauterbach sie haben aufmerksam
zugehört wenn wir menschen einsperren
und so muss man eine ausgangs
beschränkung empfinden sollte sie
wirksam sein wissen wir ob
ausgangssperren wirklich wirksam sind ja
das wissen wir sagt dazu studien gegeben
die alle ausgangs beschränkungen die
durchgeführt worden sind ausgewertet
haben in der zweiten welle und zwar im
konzert mit anderen maßnahmen die schon
ergriffen worden sind hat man die
insgesamt 117 regionen ausgewertet in
einer metaanalyse um also alle studien
die vorlagen zusammengelegt hat das hat
die oxford universität gemacht sehr
hochwertig diese studie
und da kommt heraus ist eine bestätigung
auch andere studien die nicht ganz so
gründlich gemacht worden sind in der
vergangenheit dass das also den re
produktionswert ungefähr zwischen 10 und
20 prozent im mittel um 15 prozent senkt
darüber hinaus hat man eben auch
praxisbeispiele und diese praxis
beispielen kann man wie folgt
zusammenfassen
eine welle mit b1 17 also mit dieser
deutlich stärker ansteckenden variante
ist ohne ausgangs beschränkungen noch
niemals kontrolliert worden das hat
super funktioniert in portugal in irland
in england und auch in den teilen
frankreichs wo es eingesetzt wurde somit
zusammenfasst
kann man sagen erstens es gibt hier die
wissenschaftliche evidenz die sehr hart
ausgewertet ist mit besten statistischen
verfahren und es gibt keine gegenteilige
analyse aus deutschland und zum zweiten
ist hat wo man es gemacht hat geklappt
ich will noch auf einen einzigen punkt
also in den zusammenhang hin was es ist
ganz klar dass die ausgangssperre nicht
als einzige instrument ist aber wenn wir
uns das konzert der instrumente jetzt
einmal anschauen dann müssen wir jetzt
dinge einsetzen die zusätzlich noch
etwas bringen
und da kann man folgendes sagen da
wirken testungen in schulen und
betrieben wenn sie als pflicht test
zweimal die woche gemacht werden
dann muss man sagen dass zum beispiel
freiwillige tests um in restaurants zu
gehen oder in meinetwegen geschäfte zu
gehen diese wirkung nicht haben und die
ausgangs beschränkungen funktionieren
und selbst mit den ausgangs
beschränkungen glaube ich werden wir
sehr schwer haben die dritte welle zu
bewältigen mit den diskussion estland
installationen die ich nicht
nachvollziehen ich für und ständig was
nicht funktioniert was aber im ausland
wunderbar geklappt hat so fragen wir
gleich in die runde ganz konkrete
praktische hinweis und mal kurz nach
hannover geschaut herr althusmann bei
ihnen gibt es eine ausgangs beschränkung
ab 150 er incidents das wäre in jedem
fall herr lauterbach in ihren augen zu
wenig wie rechtfertigen sie das herr
althusmann und während sie sich denn
jetzt innerhalb ihrer regierung
eigentlich einig ob sie dieses gesetz so
und zeichnen die ausgangs beschränkung
in niedersachsen sind zum teil gekippt
worden durch das oberverwaltungsgericht
von reis die verfassungsrechtliche
diskussion ausgesprochen spannend sie
ist auch wichtig und auch die
zuständigkeitsfragen bund länder
ausgesprochen wichtige diskussion aber
wissen sie was ich viel wichtiger finde
dass wir vielleicht jetzt irgendwann mal
versuchen nach zwölf monaten pandemie
einen weg zu finden indem wir uns mit
dem wir uns nicht von lockdown zu
lockern von notbremsung zur notbremsung
bewegen und dazu gehört sicherlich ein
klare definition der verhältnisse
zwischen bund und ländern
dazu gehört aber auch die frage wie
bewerten wir den incidents wert der
derzeitige incidents wert der überall
zur grundlage für entscheidung gemacht
wird
ist sicherlich zwischen 10 bis 30
prozent auch er beeinflusst von
aktuellen testung wer mehr testet wird
auch mehr infektionen aus dem dunkelfeld
die helligkeit hineinziehen das ist das
eine das andere bleibt letztendlich gibt
es außerhalb eines lockt downs außerhalb
einer notbremse weitere instrumente die
wir anwenden können gibt es auch die
möglichkeit den menschen ein stück weit
freiheit zurückzugeben unter bestimmten
bedingungen und deshalb plädiere ich
persönlich sehr dass wir bei dem
anstehenden gesetz auch öffnungsklauseln
vorsehen wir müssen auch die
wirtschaftliche seite betrachten wir
müssen natürlich die
verfassungsrechtliche seite sehen aber
wir müssen auch sehen dass dieses land
eine lebensgrundlage hat und wenn ich
weiß dass gleichzeitig in deutschland
circa 700 millionen umsatz tagtäglich
beim einzelhandel verloren gehen dann
weiß ich auch dass tausende von
existenzen in deutschland auf dem spiel
stehen als oder diese abwägung ist das
entscheidende moment was die politik in
den letzten monaten gelöst hat von daher
wird es aus ganz bestimmt wir sind uns
nein wir sind uns ja ich glaube wir sind
uns ja einig dass es ausgangs
beschränkungen ab einer hunderte
incidents ich sag noch mal neben einer
hunderter inzidenz zählen für mich
persönlich und ich glaube das ist auch
teilweise auffassung von vielen
virologen dass man und auch dem rk im
übrigen dass man darüber hinaus auch auf
die impfquote schaut dass man auf die
krankenhaus belegung die intensivbetten
schaut dass man zumindest sich ein
gesamtbild verschafft um dann eine kluge
vernünftige reaktion einleiten zu können
die inzidenz ist eine kurzfristige zahl
die kurzfristig etwas über das
tatsächliche infektionsgeschehen sagen
kann so dass man nach steuern kann
die ausgangs beschränkung bleibt für
mich und so verstehen wir es in
niedersachsen am ende auch ein stückweit
ultima ratio wir sollten zunächst einmal
alle anderen möglichkeiten ausschöpfen
das haben die länder getan aber gegen
ein mutiertes virus ist so manches kraut
eben nicht gewachsen die infektiosität
ist so enorm hoch und das verbreitet
sich so rasant dass man eben auch zu
ausgangs beschränkungen greifen kann
ob sie wirklich wirksam sind da muss ich
ein lauter aber nach meiner kenntnis
zumindest ein bisschen widersprechen es
gibt studien daher recht
aber es gibt nicht so viel belastbares
datenmaterial weltweit europaweit dass
man wirklich sagen kann die wirkung wird
das oder jenes am ende tatsächlich mit
sich bringen ich bin da ein bisschen
skeptischer was die ausgangs
beschränkung tatsächlich bringen wird
neben der verfassungsrechtliche frage
herr altmann fragen wir hier noch mal in
der runde herr scholz wir überzeugt sind
sie eigentlich dass in der zeit von 21
uhr bis 5 uhr
die knaller kontakte stattfinden die sie
jetzt unterbinden
sie sind sie davon überzeugt ich bin
überzeugt dass die auskunft beschränkung
hilft und deshalb bin ich auch davon
überzeugt dass es richtig ist sie in dem
gesetz runden reinzuschreiben wir werden
die konkreten bedingungen jetzt mit dem
bundestag und den ländern festlegen das
muss klug und lebensnah geschehen das
wird auch am ende so sein
und dann dann haben wir diese regelung
die auch für viele bürgerinnen und
bürger eine große erleichterung ist war
sie dann wissen woran sie sind also ich
bin überzeugt dass das wirksam ist und
ich akzeptiere dass man da andere
meinung haben kann nicht akzeptiere auch
dass sich da der eine oder andere auch
auf andere wissenschaftliche studien
beruf der ziemlich kalt lauterbacher
gerade benannt hat das würde ich gar
nicht in abrede stellen trotzdem glaube
ich wäre es ein verbrechen
diese möglichkeit jetzt nicht zu nutzen
angesichts der gefahren die mit den
infektionen verbunden sind und da hilft
es dann auch nicht dass wir die nächsten
30 studien abwarten bevor wir das
entscheiden wir müssen jetzt handeln und
es ist sehr gut dass die länder von sich
aus das auch machen auch die ganze zeit
schon vieles tun und wenn wir das jetzt
zusammenfassenden wird das glaube ich
uns helfen im kampf gegen die pandemie
verbrechen ist ein großes wort wir sind
bei herrn lindner und sagen
natürlich geht es nicht nur um den
joggenden parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer der spd
und es geht auch nicht nur um den hund
der aus geführt wird sondern es geht um
dass kontakte verhindern
und das trifft in allererster linie die
jugendlichen wird das erreicht werden
herr lindner glauben sie dass also in
der tat die wissenschaftliche wirkung
ist umstritten ich weiß nicht ob herr
lauterbach schon gelegenheit hatte die
jetzt gerade heute veröffentlichte
studie aus frankreich zu sehen
frankreich hat ja einen dauer lockdown
mit sehr vielen ausgangssperren gehabt
und das ergebnis dieser studie für
frankreich mit sehr vielen daten ist
dass die ausgangssperre eben nicht
wirksam war
für die stadt toulouse wird sogar die
these in den raum gestellt dass sie zu
einer gewissen verschärfung
desinfektions geschehens beigetragen
hätte ich benutze bewusst den konjunktiv
weil die menschen verdichtet dann in den
einzelhandel gegangen sind und
entzerrung nicht möglich war
durch die ausgangssperre und deshalb
muss man dieses instrument mit großer
sorgfalt einsätzen im wissen darum dass
es möglicherweise das was jetzt von ihm
erwartet wird nicht erreicht keiner kann
das oft kann er sofort sagen ich glaube
wir müssen uns zunächst auf die
maßnahmen konzentrieren die wirksam sind
das ist die beschränkung der kontakte
der haushalte fraglos schon bei der
schließung des handels in den modellen
click and collect das heißt also man
bestellt etwas und holt es ab bin ich im
zweifel ob das eine tatsächliche wirkung
auf das infektionsgeschehen hat zwar
kann menschlichen kontakt gibt ich halte
das zumindest aber für vertretbar recht
nicht vertretbar ich würds politisch so
machen die markus söder markus söder
sieht ja ab einer 200er incidents noch
diese form des termin shoppings in
bayern als notwendig an der kanzlerin
kritisiert worden
ja das kann sein aber wie auch immer
gesagt dass in nordrhein westfalen gilt
das übrigens auch insofern ist das keine
irgendwie geartete parteinahme in der
internen frage der union wenn nicht
darauf hinweisen
da ist vertretbar meine ich wenn die
regierung da sagt das wollen wir nicht
bei der ausgangssperre habe ich aus
mehreren gründen zweifel das ist zum
ersten hunderter incidents herr
althusmann hat ja gerade völlig zurecht
andere indikatoren angewendet für mich
herr althusmann wäre dann die frage an
sie wie können sie denn dieses gesetz wo
das nicht gewichtet ist wo die frage der
impfquote ist es ein cluster an einer
stelle oder es ist ein diffuses
ausbruchsgeschehen wie können sie das
gesetz dann gutheißen aber das muss
verändert werden und es gibt keine
differenzierung herr scholz zwischen
geimpften und nicht geimpften und da ist
die problematik weshalb ich sie bitten
möchte auf vokabular wie verbrechen zu
verzichten das ist ja ein strafrechtlich
relevanter sachverhalt denn ich glaube
dass großer schaden entsteht
wenn dieses gesetz dann möglicherweise
verworfen werden jetzt kommt mein
beispiel wir haben ein geimpftes ehepaar
sie leben zusammen sind geimpft
sie leben in einem land kreis und 40
kilometer entfernt so große landkreise
haben wir haben wir einen einzelnen
ausbruch und deshalb wird denen die
ausgangssperre ab 21 uhr auferlegt sie
können kein spaziergang mehr machen wenn
es draußen hell ist viele dieser dieser
älteren ehepaare werden sagen aus
solidarität bleiben wir zu hause aber im
staat des grundgesetzes braucht es nur
einen einzigen zu geben der dagegen
klagt und dann ist das ganze gesetz
nichtig mit einem großen politischen
vertrauensschaden und deshalb ist mein
dringender rat an der stelle
nachzubessern
weil ich muss auch ankündigen sollten
sie das so beschließen herr scholz dann
werden wir nächste woche in karlsruhe
klage erheben
und ich glaube dass regeln ich glaube
das sollten wir gemeinsam verhindern
indem sie einfach gut gemeinte
vorschläge im gesetzgebungsverfahren
berücksichtigt und da ist genau diese
frage frau gerade will die politik damit
er eigentlich nur ein signal aussenden
nämlich das signal bitte trefft euch
nicht und hat das aber nicht final und
klug überlegt und zu einem sauberen
gesetz gemacht ja so scheint es mir
tatsächlich zu sein
ich wundere mich auch über die
perspektiv verschiebung die hier in den
letzten monaten offenbar stattgefunden
hat also verfassungs zweifel werden
nicht richtig ernst genommen wie wir
jetzt eben gerade hier gehört habe es
ist die rede davon dass freiheit
freiheit in zurückgegeben werden habe
ich auch eben gerade hier gehört das ist
aber dass die freiheiten gehören einem
erst mal per se
der spd-politiker ducati in nrw spricht
davon dass man die menschen erwischen
wolle draußen wenn sie draußen bei
ostritz beschränkungen sind also da hat
sich so ein autoritärer ton finde ich
etabliert der eigentlich der sache auch
mich angemessen ist natürlich sind wir
uns glaube ich alle hier eigentlich es
soll schnell gehandelt werden und auch
wirksam behandelt werden aber ja diese
autoritäre ton der sich nicht nur
eingeschlichen sondern breit gemacht hat
der gilde sehr fragwürdig ist fragwürdig
ich habe mir immer noch gemerkt dass wir
herrn lauterbach gleich nach frankreich
und toulouse fragen herr scholz herr
lindner und seine fraktion seine partei
würden klagen in karlsruhe
was halten sie von einem gewichteten
incidents wert das ist der vorschlag und
was halten sie davon
geimpfte nicht so zu behandeln in bezug
auf die ausgangs beschränkungen wie
menschen die nicht geimpft sind
eine bemerkung für wirklich etwas
skeptisch bei den ganzen formulierungen
dieser diskussion aber auch vielen
anderen beginn mit zunächst einmal
müsste man folgendes machen und weit
müssen wir vieles gleichzeitig machen
wir dürfen einfach nicht aufschieben
weil wir sagen es gibt noch viele
ausflüchte und auswege sondern es ist
jetzt schon sehr ernst wir müssen in
dieser situation ein anstieg der
infektionszahlen verhindern damit die
impfkampagne und das tempo das wir dort
mittlerweile haben nicht erst viel
später wirkt die frage ob wir im sommer
die freiheiten zurück haben oder erst
sehr viel später entscheidet sich im
prinzip in den nächsten tagen
und deshalb ist es so zentral was wir
jetzt machen dass wir eine ernsthafte
diskussion über jedes detail haben es
völlig in ordnung wichtig deshalb habe
ich ihn auf eine ihrer früheren fragen
antwortet ich finde es überhaupt nicht
schlimm dass all die debatten die bisher
in jedem landeskabinett und in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
stattgefunden haben und auch im
bundestag jetzt noch einmal konkret bei
dieser gesetzgebung neu aufleben so dass
wir das möglichst gut hin gefeilt
kriegen um das sozusagen damit es ein
erstklassiges gesetz ist das mitte
nächster woche beschlossen wird
was die frage betrifft der regel der
regelung für geimpfte habe ich ja schon
vor sehr langer zeit gesagt wir werden
etwas machen müssen im hinblick auf die
em
und meine idee ist dass wir sie so
behandeln müssen wie jemanden der einen
tagesaktuellen test hat und daraus ist
geworden dass die letzte konferenz der
ministerpräsident und
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundesregierung beschlossen hat das
robert-koch-institut zu bitten uns dazu
eine expertise zu geben das haben die
unterdessen gemacht und das ist der
grund
vielleicht ein argument für sie
zuzustimmen
das sehe dass wir in das gesetz an die
rechtsverordnung eingeschrieben haben
die wir nutzen wollen um genau eine
solche regelung gut abgestimmt ländern
und bundestagsfraktion und der
wissenschaft zu standen einschreiben zu
können
das können wir dann hinterher machen und
wir haben die idee dass wenn wir das
nächste mal mit den ländern sprechen und
das wird dann natürlich eine parallele
diskussion mit dem bundestag geben wir
über die frage des impfens reden und
dann eben auch konkret über die
ausgestaltung einer solchen verordnung
okay gut das hat man verstanden und das
ist auch wichtig dass sie es noch mal
sagen dazu dient also dieser passus
wegen der verschärfung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes jetzt herr
lautlos genutzt werden wir
selbstverständlich hat er auch andere
handlungsoptionen aber das ist der zweck
für die ganze sache und darum haben wir
uns diese möglichkeit bieten bei dem
gesetz regulierungspraxis sinnvoll
solche rechtsverordnungen zu machen
ursprünglich war ja auch nicht
vorgesehen den bundestag zu fragen
trotzdem ist die regelung noch nicht so
wie sie eigentlich unter parlamentariern
sein sollte denn es ist in der
gesetzgebung jetzt vorgesehen der bund
die bundesregierung darf
rechtsverordnungen vornehmen
der bundestag kann zustimmen aber wenn
das nicht binnen sieben tage erfolgt
gilt das als eine zustimmung der
bundesregierung
da würde sich des bundestages da würde
sich jeder der privaten bauantrag stellt
freuen über eine solche genehmigungs
fiktion das werde die behörde nicht
motto pilz als genehmigt wenn ich diese
genehmigungs fiktion für private
bauherren die behörde durchgreift
durchbricht das dann auf hatte dass der
bundestag dann auch klar aber ich glaube
dass ich glaube dass diese diese frist
glaube ich für eine vertrauensbildung
noch einmal werden wir uns auch und
fallen sollte okay es keine 7
wenn wir hier mal ein politisches
gespräch vor laufender kamera für wollen
wenn ich also sagen möchte ich nur
einfach das passieren also ich möchte
mal gerne hören nicht vielleicht in
dieser sendung falls das zu früh ist
aber wenn sie so ein wenn dann satz
sagen für den fall dass wir diese
verordnungsermächtigung im hinblick auf
die regelung für geimpfte noch ein
bisschen so und so fassen auch das
parlamentsbeteiligung rechnung die fdp
dem gesetz zu hr schultern erich das
interessant für die arbeit aber da muss
ich sagen sind ihre akten vortrag nicht
gut
am sonntag habe ich der bundesregierung
auf aufforderung von der bundesregierung
selbst ja einen brief geschrieben mit
genau ausgearbeitet den sechs punkten
ich habe jetzt den einsparungen aber es
gibt schon sechs punkte
ich wollte sie auf den einen festen hp
aber wegen wegen dieser einen
selbstverständlichkeit werden sie keine
zustimmung für unsere schade für
deutschland aber sechs punkte sind ihnen
vorgelegt worden und wir könnten
sicherlich herr scholz zusammen mit
seinen kollegen wir werden natürlich
abwarten wie die parlamentarische
debatte läuft und ich möchte jetzt
unbedingt zu karl lauterbach weil wir
uns noch mal fragen herr lauterbach auf
der basis welcher welchen wissens werden
diese ausgangs beschränkungen
vorgenommen stichwort toulouse stichwort
frankreich wir sind an die also oxford
studie war eine besondere studie wie die
manchmal gemacht hat dann eine
sogenannte metaanalyse das heißt alle
erfahrungen in anderen studien werden
dann zusammengefasst und man macht dann
ein gesamturteil somit die toulouse
studie beispielsweise ist eine studie
und die wird bei der nächsten aussagen
mal ausgabe einer solchen metaanalyse
wieder oxford studium mit eingebracht
auch bei den 117 regionen die ich eben
vorgetragen habe waren solche dabei wo
das nichts gebracht hat aber wenn man
jetzt alle zusammen auswertet statistik
dann sieht man dass es der gesamtnutzen
und die studie hat auch noch eine
besonderheit und zwar schaut die auf die
kombinationen das heißt dann guckt man
was dann schon an
london maßnahmen da ist und fragt sich
was bringt zusätzlich die ausgangs
beschenken damit ist diese studie sehr
wertvoll sehr hochwertig und ja zum
beispiel dann geprüft was bringt die
ausgangssperre in einer situation wo die
geschäfte schon zu sind und wo viele
andere maßnahmen sowie bei uns schon am
platz sind was wirkt dann zusätzlich
noch wie groß die zusatz wirkung da
liegt der unterschied zu der torlos
studie die daher nicht so aussagekräftig
ist war das nur eine studie die würde
als eine von 118 dann wenn sie mit
einfließen würde hier berücksichtigt
kollegen entsprechend noch einen punkt
auch sagen bevor ich den weil das ist
wichtiger als hat man hat eben an sehr
wichtigen also punkt gemacht hat die
inzidenz angesprochen gesagt die
inzidenz alleine kann es nicht sagen
weil das kommt ja auch darauf an wie oft
man testet da ist das weit verbreitete
also in ärmlicher annehmen dass es wird
jetzt mehr mit anti gen test gearbeitet
bei asymptomatischen da wir insgesamt
mehr also getestete und daher ist die
instanz nicht so also in wirklichkeit
nicht so hoch sie würde somit hörschaden
nazis das ist aber nicht so
die anti gen tests die wir heute machen
die sind bei den automatischen
typischerweise zeigen die gar nicht an
das heißt diejenigen die mit dem antigen
test jetzt getestet werden
die wehren was sie symptomatisch sind
sowieso wenn es die test nicht gegeben
hätte am nächsten tag oder übernächsten
tag mit dem pcr getestet worden
daher ist die pcr quote nach wie vor
sehr hoch und dann würde man erwarten
dass auch sehr viel los ist auf den
intensivstationen genau das sehen wir
wir haben sogar jetzt das folgende
problem durch die anti gen test sind
viele junge leute die haben das positive
testergebnis die wissen denn sie haben
corona die versuchen alleine
durchzukommen die gehen gar nicht mehr
zum pcr die kommen dann gar nicht mehr
die statistik die kommen dann aber auf
die intensivstation und müssen dann oft
schon beatmet werden wenn sie reinkommen
das ist also eine prekäre situation
es kann daher sagen dass wir zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt die ware incidents er
unterschätzen und nicht überschätzen
und wenn man da die inzidenz bewertet
dann muss man das mitdenken da darf man
nicht den fehlschluss machen wir testen
derzeit viel daher sind die zahlen
diejenigen die uns auf den man sich
schon daran dass wir sind im
durchschnitt etwa 47 48 jahre alt das
sind menschen mitten im leben die baten
wir fünf sechs wochen lang und viele von
denen die hälfte ungefähr von den
folgenden stirbt das ist eine tragödie
und da verlieren viele kinder derzeit
ihre eltern und wir können uns daher
eine solche debatte ist das wirklich
rechtlich also hundertprozentig
ausformuliert ich verlasse mich hier
auch auf die rechtsexperten in den
zuständigen ministerien aber uns läuft
die zeit davon ich kann die debatte
überhaupt nicht verstehen und das tut
übrigens auch kein mediziner in das kann
intensivmediziner und das ist eine ganz
gefährliche diskussion zu sagen
grundrechte und verfassungsrecht das
hält uns alles auf und lasse mich was
wir in dieser serie nicht verlassen und
auf die zuständigen was der kollege
abgeordneter lauterbach für ein
parlamentarier müsste es zum
selbstverständnis gehören dass man sich
in so wichtigen grund rechtsfragen nicht
alleine nur auf die ministerien die
weisungsgebunden mit
richtlinienkompetenz arbeit
rechtsausschuss wo ich mir unseren alten
ihr eigenes bild macht und haben wir
jetzt daraus schluss also nach nächster
würde ich nochmal sagen alle hier sind
sich einig dass dinge getan werden
müssen
das wollte ich sie gerade auch fragen
wenn sie sich die institution antwort
wenn sie sich die incident zahlen
anschauen ist das eine
sie möchten dass wir gesichtete inzidenz
zahlen haben wenn sie heute auf den
blanken werte intensiv bettenbelegung
schauen müssten sie dann nicht sagen
herr lauterbach hat recht wir müssen was
tun
das ist das ein ja und selbst wenn sie
sich erinnern das war meine antwort und
ihre erste frage ob sie jetzt etwas tun
müssen und ich hatte ja auch von jetzt
testen jetzt im tempo kontakt
beschränkung wo nötig übrigens auch
sagen wir mal offen
aufklärung über die gesundheitlichen
risiken auch in anderen als den
deutschen in der deutschen sprache weil
wir eine sehr starke diskussion führen
müssten darüber ob wir eigentlich alle
teile der bevölkerung erreicht scheine
sich schon vor einem halben jahr hat es
ja denn wir sind ja immer sehr
vorsichtig mit dieser argument
hier geht es darum den schutz und da
gibt es eben doch evidenz dass menschen
mit migrationshintergrund nicht über die
gesundheitlichen risiken in gleicher
weise aufgeklärt sind auch so eine art
von sofortmaßnahme die manns einleiten
müßte aber alle schreibt all das werde
dass sie alle reichend regierung liegen
ja eben weil trockenlegen müssen wir
doch also feulner
wir können ja alle unterschiedlicher
meinung sein aber ich lege schon wert
darauf dass die maßnahmen der pandemie
bekämpfung vereinbar sind mit unserem
grundgesetz und wir uns hier nicht
gewöhnen an eine form des ausgaben
verantwortlich sind und dass eben man
dann auch sagen muss dass man da meint
also ich finde jetzt muss viel getestet
werden deshalb haben wir die tests
zentren überall in deutschland
eingerichtet da gibt es jetzt sehr viele
das ist nicht so schnell die gänge kommt
wie sie sich wahrscheinlich jeder
gewünscht hätte und jede aber das ist
jetzt da wir testen in den schulen
verpflichtend zweimal das wird auch in
diesem gesetz stehen aber das ist auch
schon vielfach vorbereitet das ist also
jetzt etwas was wir auch als realität
neu wahrnehmen
es hat eine nicht ganz erfolgreiche aber
doch engagierte kampagne der unternehmen
gegeben das testen in den betrieben
durchzusetzen und wir machen das jetzt
verpflichten so dass das bei den übrigen
auch noch klappt das wird dazu führen
dass das testen ein neuer teil der
realität sein wird und das ist also auch
gemacht wir haben beschränkungen was die
öffnung von geschäften betrifft von
dienstleistungen haben dabei auf die
gute praxis und übrigens weitgehend auf
die formulierung von länder verordnung
zurückgegriffen bei dem entwurf des
bundesgesetzes also der praxis von
ländern die uns gut gefallen haben und
wir haben dann immer und wir haben dann
gefallen und die auch juristisch sehr
gut sind und sauber durchdacht sind und
viele probleme schon berücksichtigt
haben und wir sagen eben zu all diesen
maßnahmen dazu gehört auch eine ausgabe
beschränkung mit öffnung stylen die
dafür dazu beitragen dass es eine
angemessene und verhältnismäßige
maßnahme
was mir auch noch richtig ist das will
ich gern noch dazu sagen
die ausgangs beschränkung in anderen
ländern man teilweise viel härter und
ich glaube dass das auch eine der
ursachen dafür ist warum sie manchmal
nicht so wirksam gewesen sind weil wir
machen jetzt an die regelung für abend
wo die meisten menschen ohnehin nicht
sich bewegen wir haben ausnahmen
verwirkliche tätigkeit für den bestand
des grundgesetzes der in seinem
grundrecht jetzt den rechen
eingeschlagen sowie solaris deshalb
wissen dass deshalb weiß ich auch er
verstehe nicht warum sie diese
rechtlichen zweifel die ja sogar in
ihrer eigenen bundestagsfraktion
bestehen die rechtlichen zweifel
bestehen auf der fachebene des
kanzleramtes sie bestehen auf der ebene
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ihre
heißt ab und macht halt und eine weitere
frau hat eine ausgangs beschränke und
rheinland pfalz aber auch hinter ganz
anderen usern das nein unsere ganz
anderen bedingungen
deshalb sage ich nein herr lindner
sirion programm ich werde gar nicht drum
rum wie werden sie aus der sache nicht
gerät das werden wir ja sehen wenn
karlsruhe geurteilt hat und sie haben
jetzt ja sehr selbstbewusst gesagt dass
er alles verhältnismäßig wir werden
sehen ob das denn beschlossen wird er im
deutschen bundestag oder ob die rechts
bedenken auch ihrer fraktion nicht
durchschlagend sind und wir werden sehen
wie karlsruhe argumentiert mit dem
selbstbewusstsein wie sie hier sicher
sind das wäre ich an ihrer stelle nicht
ich wünsche ihnen fast dass sie recht
behalten damit die menschen nicht
irritiert sind welche regelungen einer
regierung und die spd beschließt aber
trotzdem muss die grund
rechtskonformität geprüft werden wenn
sie eine so wacklige regelung bestätigt
dass noch mal sagen die grund
rechtskonformität muss geprüft werden
sie ist geprüft worden
und natürlich gibt es bei diesen sachen
immer zwei meinungen wenn die tatsache
dass es welche gibt die das anders sehen
dazu führt dass wir gar nichts mehr
machen können haben wir auch ein großes
problem
deshalb gehört es schon dazu dass man
sich auch in einer solchen situation
entscheidet und ich jedenfalls habe mich
entschieden der sehr weit verbreiteten
und aus meiner sicht gut begründeten
auffassung das abgewogene mit ausnahmen
versehen eine ausgangs beschränkung für
einen kurzen zeitraum in der nacht
zulässig sind
und ich glaube dass die wirkung die das
hat für das infektionsgeschehen auch
sehr sehr hilfreich es wert ist okay